>>Marilyn: Please give a warm
Neil Cummins Hawks welcome
to Mr. Michael Pritchard.
>>Michael: Oh, thank you, Marilyn.
Oh, you're awesome, I love you.
[applause] How many of you know
a boy or girl here at school
who gets picked on and
left out and never included
and laughed at all the time?
Raise your hands high, High,
Look around the room please.
Hands down, this is
not how we want to live
or how we want to treat each other.
This is not how we want to be.
>>Narrator: Michael Pritchard
is a commanding presence,
even in an auditorium full
of normally noisy students,
teachers, and parents.
>>Michael: [car sound effect]
>>Students: [laughter]
>>Narrator: He served as a medic
in Vietnam, and has won awards
as both a stand-up comic and a
probation officer in San Francisco.
>>Michael: I love it
when babies walk.
They go-- [laughter]
>>Narrator: Over the years, he and
his wife have helped raise more
than 100 children, including three
of their own, adding a wealth
of material to the comedy
routines he has performed
in nightclubs and on TV.
>>Michael: My little boy comes in at
like three o'clock in the morning.
"Dad, I don't get any mail."
>>Narrator: And whether
he's making them laugh.
>>Michael: [laughs]
You are so stupid.
>>Narrator: Or making them shout.
>>Michael: The good you do--
>>Students: The good you do--
>>Michael: Will come back to you.
>>Students: Will come back to you.
>>Narrator: His message
is always the same.
>>Michael: And no matter
what we teach your brains,
love is more important
than knowledge.
>>Narrator: Pritchard spends most
of his time these days traveling
around the country, taping PBS
specials as he talks to and listens
to young people to find out what
they are thinking and feeling.
>>Marilyn: At one point,
Michael asks kids to come forward
and share how they've been hurt,
or maybe to apologize to others.
And when he asked them
to do that, I thought,
"They're not going to do this.
I mean, in front of all these kids,
they're not going to come forward."
I have to tell you, I was amazed at
how free they were to come forward
and really share their experience in
a way that I truly did not expect.
>>Student: When I first moved here
a year ago, no one really wanted
to play with me and all the
fifth graders called me names.
>>Michael: What was it
doing to your heart?
>>Student: It just made
me feel really bad.
>>Michael: And what I try to
teach the kids is that we have
to be more real about our emotions.
And back to the time of
Macbeth, Shakespeare said,
"Always give sorrow words.
Grief that doesn't speak whispers
to the over-fraught heart
and bids it to break."
>>Student: My main
thing that's gotten me
through all this is empathy.
I-- when the-- I was being bullied,
I tried to feel how they were feeling
and that's why they were--
and why they were bullying me.
>>Michael: And what did it do for
you to put yourself in their shoes
and know that they were hurting
you because they were hurting?
>>Student: They-- I could feel
their hurt really deep down,
and I wanted to help.
>>Michael: When I was a
kid, I guess I learned
that the most powerful gift I could
do for my friends was to help them
with their emotions, to be
there and listen to them talk.
>>Chloe: Well, last year,
when I was in my other school,
people used to call me
names because I was anemic.
>>Michael: And what was
it doing to your heart
when they were saying that, Chloe?
>>Chloe: It was putting my heart
and my mom's heart really bad.
It hurt.
>>Michael: We get sick if we
try to hold all the pain in.
And then the unaddressed grief turns
to anger, and the anger to rage.
And it has two directions, out to the
community or inwards towards the self
and self-destructiveness.
>>Student: I'm really shy right here.
>>Michael: You can do it.
>>Student: My friend was really
hurt because they called him fat.
And I didn't want that to happen,
because it wasn't [inaudible].
>>Michael: Was it fair
to him or fair to you?
>>Students: No.
>>Michael: How should
we treat each other?
>>Student: Very well.
Because if we treat each other
really bad, we won't like get along
or be friends or like
be part of a big family.
>>Michael: You know what?
You go home and you tell your mom--
look at me, you have corazon, amigo.
Yo te amo.
I love you.
>>Student: Gracias.
>>Michael: All right.
Por nada. Okay.
A big round of applause.
>>Narrator: After the assembly,
Pritchard shared lunch with members
of the school student
council to reinforce some
of the lessons they had just learned.
>>Michael: Why do you think
sometimes kids choose to be bullies,
and how can we help them
choose not to be bullies?
>>Student: Kind of walk
up to them and say,
"could you please stop that?"
>>Michael: Yeah.
Why is it--
>>Marilyn: Creating an environment
in which kids feel comfortable,
in which they are productive,
in which they treat one another
well, is not a one-shot thing.
>>Michael: What is his tactic?
Fear?
>>Student: Yeah.
He's scared, so he takes
it out on other people.
>>Michael: Right.
>>Marilyn: So our responsibility
as adults that work with kids is
to reiterate that lesson.
To keep it focused in their minds
so that it isn't something
that's easily forgotten.
And it's been my experience
it takes three to five years
to really change a school
culture to the point
where that is the expected norm
and where kids will uphold it.
And it's a learning process.
>>Student: It shouldn't be a world of
hate, it should be a world of love.
>>Michael: Yeah.
>>Narrator: While students at
elementary schools are generally open
to discussing their feelings,
students at most high
schools are not.
>>Michael: -- helping
us know that life is
about the choices that we make.
And we care about you.
>>Narrator: At Castlemont High
School in Oakland, California,
two students were wounded in
a drive-by shooting in front
of the auditorium last year.
And the initial reception
for Pritchard here was icy.
>>Michael: You're ugly.
No, I mean for real, ugly.
>>Narrator: He began
the program with some
of the same jokes he used
on the fourth graders.
>>Michael: You look like you fell out
of the ugly tree and hit every limb
on the way down [laughter]
>>Narrator: But his
material soon changed tone.
>>Michael: Little kid at
West Paducah, Kentucky,
had never fired a gun before, but
he had an eight-round capacity
and he played a lot of
point-and-shoot video games.
He hit five of his
classmates in the head.
We're talking to your hearts today.
>>Student: Why?
>>Michael: Well, I'll
tell you why I'm here.
Because I have two young African
American youngsters that grew
up with me and my family
and I love them,
and I'm worried about their lives.
You don't know that about me.
You don't know anything about me.
I'm just the big fat
guy telling you jokes.
But listen, I'm just telling you,
this isn't anger, this is love.
>>Narrator: When it came
time for students to talk,
the first volunteers were greeted
with a mixture of laughter
and taunts.
>>Students: [inaudible]
>>Student: Hey, I'm going
to just keep it real.
>>Michael: Shh.
>>Narrator: But one by one,
other students found the courage
to speak from their hearts.
>>Student: I love my mom, but
my mom got serious problems.
I'm like, serious, right?
I actually took from my mama.
I took 300 dollars from my mama
just so she couldn't smoke.
You feel me?
By me doing it, I mean, it hurt
her, because she wanted to smoke,
but it hurt be because I didn't
want her to smoke, feel me?
So I'm trying to help her, but
I'm hurting her at the same time.
>>Student: Everybody's talking
about, "Yeah I'm fixing to go home
and eat this and eat that."
I was fixing to go home and look
at the TV because it ain't nothing
in my refrigerator but
some ice cubes and water.
That don't feel right at all.
And see, people think that's
funny because it sounds funny.
But when you got to walk and step
in them shoes, it ain't funny.
And it ain't cool, because I
got a seven year old brother.
I got a seven year old brother.
Little boys like to eat.
They like to eat, because
they're hungry.
>>Student: Seeing as how dudes
call girls like rippers and renders
and bitches and stuff like that.
>>Michael: Listen please.
>>Student: It opened my
mind not to judge girls,
because they're going through stuff.
I learned like one out of every three
girls has been sexually assaulted.
And that's all I'm saying.
>>Michael: They always say,
"Oh, nobody will get up,"
and the parents-- and this
tells you I think in a lot
of ways how disconnected
parents and teachers can be
from the courage of children.
>>Student: You all might
think my life is perfect.
I have both of my parents,
sisters, or whatever.
And I'm talking to all of you all
dudes out there that have some kind
of addiction, because
my dad has an addiction.
I've always had to live with a father
that would get his paycheck Friday,
go into a bar, and not come
back until three in the morning
or not even come back Friday night.
And waiting up for him.
>>Michael: What has it
done to your heart, hon?
>>Student: It hurts, because
I love him, and I don't want
to feel all this-- all this-- all
these negative feelings towards him.
Because I love him, but at the
same time, I hate him so much
for what he has done to my mom.
He wasn't there for her, and
he barely was there for me.
But I'm going to be somebody.
I'm going to be what
my sister wanted to be,
I'm going to accomplish her dream.
>>Michael: That strength of character
to get up and stand up for yourself
and others and to help others
try and be more compassionate,
if we can tap into that as a
resource for the world, this apathy,
this neglect, this
indifference is going to end.
And that's the beginning of peace.
>>Michael: Shh, Listen please.
>>Student: I just wanted to
apologize to two young ladies--
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.